On,
um,
is there ever a legitimate use for human
rights tribunal or counsel?
And if you could comment also,
I'm going forward in the fight over
gender expression,
gender identity,
um,
how do people combat or,
or,
or win that fight in front of human
rights?
Uh,
courts and tribunals and um,
yeah,
we'll leave it at that.
Oh no,
there is no excuse for them.
That's why they're called social justice
tribunals in Ontario like that.
That's what they're called.
And so look it up yourself and that's
what they are.
So we had a court system that works
perfectly well,
which doesn't mean it worked very well,
but it means it works better than any
alternative.
And if anyone has ever been able to
think up and a human rights tribunal can
suspend nor normal jurisprudential
standards,
they use preponderance of evidence.
They don't assume individual innocence
and they can change the rules as they
see fit.
And so those bloody things are
pathological to the core and their,
their mouthpieces of the postmodernist
neo Marxists as far as I'm concerned.
And they're setting up a parallel law
system and they're also doing that
there also,
and this is,
this is the wind government,
they're also forcing the universities to
adopt particular definitions of sexual
harassment that make every,
let's call it complicated interchange
between human beings into a act of
violence.
Not that I'm trying to justify stupidity
or oppression,
but we're all stupid and we're all
oppressors.
And so the probability that we'll make
some sort of dopey sexual error is 100
percent and now that's become grounds
for,
you know,
accusations of rape and where they're
forcing the universities and the
colleges to become parallel legal
systems as well.
And that's already well advanced.
It's already been adopted at the UFT.
It's as a consequence of direct
legislation and you better look out
because even if the people who are
running those institutions right now are
reasonable,
which they're not,
they will absolutely be replaced by
people who exactly want that kind of
power and will absolutely use it.
So no,
those things should be abolished.
We have a legal system,
no
law society now.
I may not have this exactly right,
but I've got it mostly right.
The Lost Society in Ontario has already
decided that lawyers are racists.
They're going to force them to undergo
on unconscious bias training and they've
come to and they were agreeing by the
way they've already come to the
conclusion that because the legal
profession does not have the precise
representation that you would expect if
you did a demographic analysis of the
population according to the terms
defined by the social justice warriors,
that it's racist and that they're racist
and that they need to be trained
unconscious first.
It's like,
so go ahead.
Lawyers like lineup man,
admit your guilt.
You're done and you deserve it too.
So yeah.